one of the real problems we've seen
under the current administration is the
weaponization of propaganda to a degree
that we didn't see under Barack Obama we
didn't see under george w bush we didn't
see under bill clinton we didn't see
under george HW bush administrations it
doesn't mean those administrations
didn't propagandize to some degree
doesn't mean they didn't do bad things
but it is a level that we have never
seen before under donald trump and a
very reliable propaganda tool whenever
Donald Trump fails
whenever Donald Trump embarrasses the
country whenever Trump's actions lead to
suffering or to death or to plunder or
whatever it is is to what go back to
revert to fake news lamestream media
okay that's the technique at any time
it's like a get out of jail free card
for Donald Trump whenever he fails us
once again which is almost daily under
the umbrella of the virus the focus
becomes Lake lamestream media fake news
okay he's failed on the prevention well
it's a fake news is lying about it he's
failed on the suppression the lamestream
media is not being fair to him he's
failing on mitigation governors are
lying about how many ventilators they
need he's failing on science he's
failing on common sense and so Donald
Trump has shifted almost exclusively to
attacking media coverage of his handling
of the corona virus pandemic rather than
actually dealing with the caseload and
the death toll and everything that's
going on Trump tweeting quote because
the ratings of my news conferences are
so high bachelor finale Monday night
football type numbers according to the
New York Times the lamestream media is
going crazy
Trump is reaching too many people we
must stop him said one lunatic
see you at 5:00 p.m. from preferring to
his press conference yesterday then
going on to tweet again about the
ratings of his press conferences and
remember at the press conferences he
barely talks about the virus itself he
focuses on self congratulation and that
according to the New York Times he says
President Trump is a ratings hit since
reviving the daily White House briefing
mr. Trump and his car
virus updates have attracted an average
audience of 8.5 million on cable news
roughly the viewership of the season
finale of The Bachelor numbers are
continuing to rise on Monday nearly 12
point 2 million people watched the
briefing Monday night football numbers
millions are watching on ABC CBS NBC and
online streaming and the audience is
expanding on Monday Fox News alone
attracted 6 million viewers an
astounding number for 6 p.m. cable
broadcast more akin to the viewership
for a popular primetime sitcom the CBS
News poll said 13 percent of Republicans
trusted the news media for information
about the virus he's comparing press
briefings to The Bachelor he's comparing
press briefings about a virus that is
leading to people dropping dead more
every day - a reality show and what he
fails to understand because it's it's
too difficult I guess for him to
understand anything but the most
simplistic analysis people aren't
watching like they watch The Bachelor
people don't watch your press briefings
for entertainment they're watching
because more and more people are getting
sick more and more people are dying and
people are scared they're at home
increasingly which is good and they find
out the president is going to talk about
what is going on and they want to see
something reassuring they want to hear
something that would be akin to I
understand the difficulty and this is a
tragedy and we're losing good people but
here's what instead Trump is talking
about the popularity of the briefings
and in the briefings congratulate
himself attacks journalists endlessly
here's Trump talking about his ratings
during yesterday's press briefing the
American public ultimately they should
be the decider it's like if they don't
want to watch they shouldn't watch and
we shouldn't have bigger ratings in The
Bachelor or as the New York Times said
we have Monday Night Football type
ratings now I didn't say that I have no
idea what they are in a sense but I know
that the times they say it's all the
news that's fit to print I say it's all
the news it's not fit to print because I
think they are not honest people but
that's okay but they can't help it but
even they said
the ratings are like Monday Night
Football ratings and that these are like
bachelor finale that's there and when
the big deal happened I have no idea
what happened because I'm too busy
working and there's some day you will
tell me what happened people are dying
and Trump is tweeting and talking about
his ratings for when he actually is
failing to deal with the issue instead
attacking media and talking about the
people the fact that people watch the
press conferences and of course
constantly saying nobody's giving me
credit nobody's giving me credit
meanwhile the bodies are literally
piling up here's an image of a truck and
an ambulance bay at a New York hospital
yesterday taken by a nurse the bodies
literally piling up
it's truly sick and it's sociopathic and
wolf that word will come up again when
we hear from dr. Justin Frank a little
bit later today
he's the grim reaper of ratings so to
speak the more people die the more
people watch his briefings and he
interprets that as satisfaction with the
briefings as the fact that the briefings
are entertaining and of course ignores
the reality that more and more people
are watching because more and more
people are home and scared with each
passing day the American public is more
and more concerned with the fiasco that
has become our government's response to
this pandemic that's why people are
watching to try to figure out is there
anything on the horizon that might help
this and when they tune in and they see
Trump a talk attacking journalists
saying don't be a cutie-pie
that's a nasty question etc people are
disgusted they're not watching like they
watch The Bachelor but that's all Trump
seems to care about